so hello everybody thank you for
introduction actually I prepared a slide
for introducing me but it seems that
it's not needed so yes I work at
Anaconda this is my Twitter GitHub
handle these are some of the projects
which I am uh involved with uh I'm
working on anaconda on Pi script Pi
script is python in the browser maybe
we'll talk it about a bit more later and
that's why I became interested in
webassembly in the last year more or
less and so yes this is why I decided to
do this talk because it's a nice
technology is very promising everybody
talks about it let's try to understand
what it is so webassembly
hey it's it's cool technology apart that
it's not web and not assembly but apart
from this like it we will see why in in
which sense it's not webinar assembly
but like it's it's not really for the
web like it's used in the web it's
useful for the web but it it's much
broader than this and that's why I I'm
excited about the technology because I
think it can be a revolution and we'll
be used in many many fields and actually
it's not an assembly usually with
assembly you mean a language but like
it's not a language that you write in
so what is it I did what everybody does
these days I asked to chat to GPT
and so webassembly is a binary
instruction format for a stack-based
virtual machine
so this is the important part so it's
it's a virtual machine a virtual machine
is basically that's it's a it's a CPU
that's what that's why the title uh it's
a virtual CPU which can execute binary
code
for a specific instruction set
and of course it is available in the
browsers so it's it's a web standard and
all the browsers old modern browsers
including the mobile the ones the mobile
can support webassembly so basically you
have a virtual machine which runs in
your browser and and can run low level
code
uh
and and this makes it the most
ubiquitous virtual machine ever because
if I compile something on webassembly I
can run it literally everywhere
and
this is like one of the reason why why
it's so cool honestly uh
another important property of
webassembly is that it's completely
sandboxed and safe we will see later
what it means but generally speaking it
means that you can execute arbitrary
code untrusted code of webassembly in
your browser or on your server and and
you can be sure that
this arbitrary code cannot make any harm
to your system
it's a virtual machine and like if you
if if you want to execute a program
which was compiled to webassembly you
need a runtime to execute it as I said
all the browsers include a webassembly
virtual machine nowadays but is there is
they are not alone so you can use
webassembly in node for example node.js
so like without the browser
and but you can also use other runtimes
for example there is one time which is
one of the most popular one there has
results man there are a lot of them like
yesterday I was looking on Wikipedia and
like there are like 20 of them but yes
each of them with pros and cons and then
the various uh yes different properties
I hinted at the fact that like
webassembly we can think of it as a CPU
so we can compile languages to it and
the the interesting fact is that
webassembly was designed with with the
idea that you can compile C code and C
plus plus code to it
and it's designed to be fast so that
it's it's a bit slightly higher level
than for example x86 or arm but it's low
level enough that the web assembly
runtime which can be for example a jit
compiler can generate machine code which
is almost as fast as native code so like
this is why it's also important because
you can get near native performance and
and again since it's ubiquitous it's
like compiled ones run everywhere uh
and if you think about it this is kind
of the same problem is that Java said 20
years ago like a compile a compiled ones
run everywhere but the big difference
between Java and web assembly like the
jvm and webassembly is that webassembly
is a low level virtual machine like it's
it's it talks about
pointers and and integers and floating
points it doesn't have any notion of
objects or interfaces or or things like
this and and this is a a is a good
Target for C and and that's why you can
take a lot of Legacy code uh and compile
it webassembly and with enough effort it
works so it's a low level virtual
machine which will be nice to call it
llvm as expect that we cannot because
llvm was already taken by something
which is not in virtual machine it's a
compiler because this reminds me that
like naming is very hard in computer
science and we as a as a computer
science we are not very good at it but
yes anyway
webassembly
[Music]
um
I I I could decide in many different
directions for for this talk and
at first I would like to go a bit low
level like and understand exactly what
it is under the hood I I cannot go too
much in deep in depth because I don't
have enough time but uh let's start like
we have a very simple function in C
and which compute the factorial number I
hope it's correct
and we can compile with assembly like
this is just like this is the the the
the command line don't don't spend too
much looking at it like we can use
silang which has a web assembly backend
so let's take a mid web assembly code
and I pass this option and I get a
factory that was which is the output
file and let's see what is inside
and
now I'm going to show you a disassembled
version of the binary so the the
compiler emits the
binary code but then we there is like we
can disassemble it and see on a human
readable way what's inside this format
is called a webassembly text format and
it's abbreviated as what
and this is the main reason why I want
to talk about this because I want to
include this slide
and it looks like this uh so this is
like the factorial function that we were
before that we we saw before and you get
a webassembly module so it's like the
the assemble the what format is
um showed informal uh s expression so
it's similar to lisp but like the actual
the actual uh syntax is not very
important but it's important to
understand what are the underlying
um
properties so in a webassembly module we
have one or many functions
and in this case we have this one which
has a type which was declared somewhere
else but basically type of factorial is
you take an integer and you return an
integer and you see that you take a e i
32 parameters and it returns an i32 so
it's like
straightforward translation from C and
then you have this kind of thing so you
can have a local variable which is again
a neither two we have another one this
is I suppose it is the what in C was the
variable address
which hold the result and T is probably
the variable I for the for Loop and then
you have this kind of instruction so you
can see like
it's it's
low level enough so that that's if
you're as a compiler you can emit code
easily
map into it
and and if you are a web assembly
runtime you can easily with enough
quotes emit assembly code for it in a
fast and efficient way because this
local variable becomes a CPU register
and and TS becomes a move and and things
like this and this is the core of the of
the logical factorial so we have a loop
and at the end of the loop we Branch
back to the label L1 which is the start
of the loop and inside the loop you can
see that for example this is I Plus 1.
and so we we
get the local variable L2 which was I we
add it with one and then we multiply it
with rest and we store it again and blah
blah so this is
webassembly I'm not going
because like we need two hours if if I
go more details but at least you have a
brief understanding of what it is
and once I have a webassembly module
I can run it and as I said we can run it
in
in different contexts
the the most useful will use the
context nowadays is inside the browsers
so we can use JavaScript to fetch
instantiate a web assembly module and
get
reference to the functions in it so this
is the code
it's not important to go in detail so
like this is like yes the the JavaScript
API to instantiate the web assembly
module and then once we have it we can
get the exports which are the function
which are available from the outside and
then I get a reference to the factorial
and then I can for example
ask JavaScript to call the webassembly
function which was written in C and ask
for the result and let's see if the live
demo works
it works good
but the the the the other cool thing is
that as I said it's ubiquito so you
don't have to
um
to use JavaScript or the browser like we
we have TC function we compile it to
webassembly we run in the browser but we
can also store it somewhere on our
machine and run it from python
and and for running it from python we
mean we we need a
um web assembly runtime in this case I'm
using the wasman time module
from python you can just PP install
what's time or cone install once time
since I worked for Anaconda and uh and
the interior is the API again I don't
know I just copied and paste like I I
you it's not important the details and
but then you get a python function that
you can call passing the numbers and and
it's fast like it's much faster than
python so
um it's it's a good way for for
embedding code
which for some reason maybe you don't
want to you you need it faster than C
then python maybe for some reason you
don't want to allow arbitrary untrusted
code uh written in C because arbitrary
code between C can be unsafe so for
example it's very common to use
webassembly for plugins if you have a
big application you can use
webassembly like you can tell people
that they can write plugins in
webassembly and you can run them
in a safe way and knowing that they
cannot get other data and crush your
application or whatever
I'm not going to demo this like guess
like it it's it works and it prints 120
but yes
so
very brief overview of what is low
assembly we can compile C chords Plus or
assembly scripts or rust or whatever to
over assembly and we can run it what you
can do with webassembly
the first thing you can do is
computation you can burn your CPU
because you can do a lot of factorials
Fibonacci and lots of commutation blah
blah blah blah blah with integers and
numbers and floats
and that's it
like you cannot do anything else
like by default and uh
webassembly itself can only compute
numbers
and you don't have access to the file
system you cannot do any network call
you can do any IO get input from you
from the user you cannot access any
system call you don't have even things
that you can get for granted like the
let me see let's see you don't have
the ABS function from the ellipse or or
things like this
which I I I mean what's happening here
why why everybody is using web assembly
and the tricky part like the the Escape
Edge is what what are called Imports so
in in a web assembly module you can
declare functions which are imported
from the outside and they can be called
from webassembly again at like in a fast
way
and and and they can be used to augment
the functionality of of webassembly
which by default is as we saw very very
limited
and so we have a host that in our
example where JavaScript in the first
case and python the second case and we
can
provide function like the host can
provide function to the webassembly
module so for example
um yes I can let's see in the in the in
the in the next slide a common example
is a file system so if suppose I am a
program and I want to open a file or
write to disk and
at the sea level what you need to do is
to call open and read and write which
our system calls but by default they
don't work like there is no way of
calling them but the host can provide
these functions to the to the web
assembly module and it's completely over
control like they all completely control
the behavior of this function so one
possible implementation is just forward
it to the operating system and let the
webassem module see the real file system
so if I open ATC past VD then I I can
get it but another option is that the
host can fake a completely visual effect
system so like it intercept the the open
system call and they say yes
the file blah blah blah contains this
bytes
and if you write to something instead of
right into the disk you write some
buffering memory and then I can later
read it
and and and you can see why you can do
sandboxing with webassembly because
again it's it's similar to having a
container but it's much faster much
less convoluted and a smaller footprint
um
yes
files are just an example but you can
apply this
[Music]
this concept to everything like like
including Network calls
so
what we had so far is webassembly which
by itself can only do computations then
you can have Imports that can expose
like field fill the gaps
but if you have to do everything
manually then it's it's impossible like
you cannot re-implement all the system
calls of physics and Linux every time
you want to compile something so there
are solutions for this
and there are two big Solutions the
first is M scripting and scripting is
like a project which aims to make make
it possible to take Legacy code which
expect a lot of functionalities from the
system so the libc files networks like
various libraries and and
package everything into an SDK which you
can use to compile things to webassembly
so instead of calling GCC you call EMCC
and M script then does a lot of things
for you and from the point of view of
your C program you are in a normal
environment you can open files you can
do Network and blah blah blah but for
example the file system is completely
virtual which means that when you
instantiate your webassembly application
from JavaScript you decide what's in in
what is inside the file system and this
is a way for example to run in Python we
will see it later
and M scripting
implements most of this runtime library
for
emulate in the operating system in
JavaScript which means that if you
compile something with enscription you
can run it in the browser where you have
JavaScript of course or with node.js
because node.js is adjustable machine so
it can run the JavaScript code but for
example not with time because
you you don't have like the the
JavaScript interpreter for for the
runtime system
another another alternative is Wazi
uh which is webassembly system interface
I think we can think of it as a standard
library of imports so what happens is
that for getting scripting for for a
moment and you are writing your C
program and you want access to the file
system or to the network and Etc and you
unless you see that you are writing the
same Imports again and again so a group
of people start to sit down and
decide standard and say that we should
have this function for opening the file
key function for writing this function
for reading this function for HTTP this
function from writing to the network and
blah blah blah and and the result is
Wazi which contains many subsections and
it's like it's a convention it's a
standard so that the user program and
the
also in the runtime can talk to each
other in a standard way so that whenever
I want to open a file I I know how to do
it
and um
and uh yes
was it contains many parts and for
example a host can decide to support
only some part or only another some
other depending on on what the the
the user mode you'll need
or the user module can can request
certain capabilities and things like
this again it's provided by the host and
the host can decide if you want that for
example the file system is
is the real one or the virtual one like
it gives you a lot of flexibility
uh
it can still be used in in a browser
because since webassembly was is just a
set of imports you can Implement them in
JavaScript similar to what M script and
did and have a polyfilled version of
wasi for the browser
um so this is like a very brief very
quick
explanation of webassembly so far but
there are many many more features coming
in the next
months and and probably years because
what's what happened with webassembly is
that they developed what it's called the
MVP my number of viable product which
which is the minimal set of feature
which was useful and it was useful for
legacy
um uh Legacy application
Standalone self-contained but then they
start to add more and more feature and
the web assembly virtual machine is
becoming higher level like a steel level
for for performance but it's getting
higher level features for example
exception handling or Garbage Collection
so that you can integrate with the
average collection of JavaScript or it's
getting
similar instructions for uh
vectorization and things like this and I
feel this is my personal opinion I think
that what will happen is that
webassembly will become a a standard
virtual machine for multi-language
interpretation so imagine that you can
throw an exception from C plus and catch
it from python or from rust or other
things like this thing that currently
they are not possible but if everybody
speaks the same low level language which
is webassembly they should become
possible so I think that this is what
will happen in the next years but we are
not there yet
since we are at phyton conference what
is the relationship between was and
Python and
you can compile python to Osman which
means that python is written in C it's
an interpreter you can compile the
python interpreter to wasp and and then
run your python code in a virtual
machine which runs inside valve so you
have a virtual machine on top of another
virtual machine and this is like you can
take vanilla C Python and convert it to
what when it works but uh you don't have
access to the browser for example
because it just was
and then you have Pi died which is a
python distribution for webassembly
which included python
plus tons of already compiled scientific
libraries non-piece Pi pandas like a lot
of libraries works out of the box with
pyrodite and then you have ways to
interoperating with JavaScript so from
python you can
run document.getter Elements by ID and
and do all the web stuff
you have Micro python which is
for microcontrollers but it's also
compatible to webassembly and it has a
much smaller footprint and it's faster
to load
and and all of this is the foundation of
our PI script which is what I am working
on and it's a way to run easily python
in the browser and we the last weeks as
Anaconda we launched by speed.com which
is basically a hosting server service
for this kind of things it's different
than normal Python and web because
normally Python and like if you use
Python for the web you use it in the
backend here we're using the front end
like the computation runs on the browser
which completely Game Changer so this is
the last slide how much time I have
perfect
I think that we can go to questions
there
so thank you Antonio for this super
interesting insights into version
and well
I think we got questions or are there
already some questions in the room
because we got one on slider but when
we're in the room
no then we just start with the slider
one when it opens so how is it possible
for Verizon to be fast if provided with
slow python functions databases data
classes
uh I mean it's as fast as like python is
it cannot be faster on Watson than on
x86
what happens is that you compile python
virtual machine to us and and and use it
to interpret your Python program so your
Python program is still interpreted and
it actually it's a bit slower because
webassembly is near native performance
because I still have to do a bit of
check about memory and to be to make
sure that you cannot access memory
outside what what is provided uh so yes
I don't know if I answered the question
if the the author is in the audience
let's let me know if I didn't answer the
question but yes
question from the room otherwise we
proceed with slider that's what I'm
about the question in person not then um
suppose I'm compiling a piece of python
that reads from a file that's the
compilation simply crashes
okay I think there is again a confusion
because you don't compile a piece of
python which reads a file
like the Python program is interpreted
by the python virtual machine which is
compiled to wasp
so the the what what happened is that if
you have your open statement in Python
well you ask C python well open the file
and see python internally it's implement
it using F open actually not really but
yeah let's fake and uh and then F open
is implemented by the runtime depending
on what to use for compiling so if you
compile it using M scripting which is
what piudi does well the F open is
implemented by the M scripted runtime so
you get access to a virtual file system
which is which you control you you like
the the
the web page control so for pi script
what happens is that when you want to
start python inside the browser
um
you we set up a virtual file system
before the start and we and in this
virtual profile system we have all the
standard Library we have all your
application files
and so when you start Python and start
python start try to import
main.fi then it open it from the virtual
file system and read it as normal so
that's that's how it works and of course
you can put also your own file so you
can put
image.jpg and if you try to open
image.jpg which is in the virtual effect
system it just works but yes I hope I
answered the question
I realized just now that I forgot an
important project in this list which is
Jupiter light which is like like Jupiter
but completely in run inside the browser
and it's
uh what based on fire diet as well so
yes sorry for forgetting it no problem
so let's proceed to the next question so
is there an advantage of using vasm and
python over directly calling C plus plus
rust code using tools like Pi O3
it depends what is your um
well yes it it really depends what is
what is the goal so if we are on the
server or on your on my laptop
what is the advantage of
it depends it depends because I can
imagine the different use cases so one
use case is I run C python on my CPU and
I import a function compiled to wasp
like the factorial example
and the advantage of TSA is safety I can
run untrusted code and if I try to run a
native code which is untrusted then I go
into troubles because untrusted code
written in C can do everything that it
was on my machine so this is the main
use case then the other use case could
be that I compiled python to wasp like C
python to one so I run pirated and in my
machine and in this case like the
advantage can be that I can sandbox the
file system for example so it's always
about safety
if I am on the server if I'm in the
browser well the the point is that you
can because you can run python the
browser and Without Walls you cannot so
I think that these are the three biggest
use case
oh
um so I'm not familiar with how popular
this technique you're mentioning is for
web applications to
have a resume interpreter and then use
Python build tourism and so on but don't
you feel that the natural progression of
all of this is for browsers to start
implementing the python interpreter
instead of JavaScript
no actually it's the opposite is that
until a few years ago if you wanted to
run something in the browser you had to
browser you needed browser support
and now you can do it without the
browser and and and this this makes it
possible a lot more experimentation and
a lot of things where uh apart python
but a lot of web standards now start in
webassembly because they experiment with
new face recognition API and and you can
write in webassembly now and you could
not write it five years ago
and and then after a while the the
people sit down and see okay this is
useful let's make it a web standard and
move it to the browser so yes in in in
this sense this can happen but the point
is that since now you cannot with
without the browser support you have a
much broader
um
possibilities I did I answer your
question or okay
[Music]
webassembly is like we can Implement
your standards yes without waiting for
the standard yes
so the 30 minutes are now over
um I have to say thank you to Antonio
thank you thank you to the audience of
upload for Antonio I think